[Applause]
thank you uh
[Applause]
wow come on come on come on in the
party's over here where's colt where's
conan come on i had to let him go
let him go we got it with tough contract
negotiation you know you gotta
you gotta cut people you kept looking
back i can't you kept i kept thinking
he's gonna he's gonna say something
no no no i wasn't gonna say anything i
knew he was coming up oh you knew oh
yeah i said come on up i love it exactly
you know this election special was
magical because there was so much at
stake for our cause it was terrifying it
was terrifying honest to god when chris
elect my executive producer said do you
want to do an election special in
showtime like we did four years ago i
said no i do not
do you remember what four years ago was
yes i'm not sure if my bone marrow can
take another one of those so i would
like to i forgot to thank the american
people for
making a much better evening
amen on that that's right yeah that's
right stephen we're we're kind of back
do you feel it do you feel like we're
back i mean tonight felt so good you
mean like post covid not quite working
not post
no but i say this is that i've had to
have a few heart to hearts with myself
recently looking at the ceiling and say
grow up you don't get to decide when
this ends put on your mask and go back
to work absolutely yeah you know what
looking at all your folks and they've
all got these big grins on their face
and they've got these images i mean what
does that do for your heart uh it makes
me so happy a ton of these people have
never a never been nominated before b
never been doing emmys before i'm like
they're not usually like this by the way
most of the time you don't win but i
mean some of these people we hired over
covey like some of my writers we hired
during kova and this is the first time
we've ever we've ever hung out where are
you going tonight
steven's picking up the tab tonight
where are you going tonight that's right
this has got to be worth something this
is
shave off a little bit of that for the
tip come on uh we're going to some good
place i don't know somebody over there
arranged for some good place with chunks
of meat and a good bar oh you should
shut it down tonight this is a big one i
hope so yes and a lot of times you guys
were rewriting the script in the mar
right i mean right before you go
literally rewrite a whole show starting
at five o'clock wow and we and we tape
at 5 30. and that's why doing a live
show was something that we could do
because
because we're used to doing it like it's
live yeah
gotta be talented
the best video i think i've seen in the
last six months is the two minutes and
six seconds with you john and jennifer
hudson singing respect on the fly take
me to that moment you just i love that
you threw caution to the wind and said
screw it
[Applause]
[Laughter]
she was like do it do it she was looking
to go like get it do it
you did it you just failed she's the
best she's that but she brings so much
joy and so does john everywhere he goes